look what they're offering us now
they're their answer is okay we've
removed God from the equation and what
do we get we get government there's a
reason why right now the idea of
socialism is suddenly popping up in
America which is the fourth genuinely
the worst set of collectivist ideas that
you could possibly ever have that
hundreds of millions of people have died
in history under and it's popping up
because if you listen to what's
happening on the Left right now
politically because they've outsourced
Scott imagine if one of those people on
stage said that they were a real
believer imagine if any of them maybe
Biden could do it but but but really the
rest of them can they would never really
say that they're a believer now I don't
know what they are and I wouldn't want
them to say anything that's not true to
themselves but they would be mocked by
by everything mainstream everything
mainstream would mock them the way that
everything mainstream mocks any
Christian that happens to because
they're usually on the right they happen
to be conservatives but look what
they're offering us now their answer is
oK we've removed God from the equation
and what do we get we get government and
they they now pray basically the
government they think that they can
figure out somehow by sitting in a room
with a bunch of other politicians and
bureaucrats the worst sort of people
that exist they I don't even mean that
to be funny I mean but that's what they
think they think that they can reach it
all of humanity in a way that will be so
much better than everything that came
before them and not only can't they they
are going to do the complete reverse so
that if for no other reason if for no
grand revelation or something like that
that would be a reason to be respectful
of people that are believers because
they can fight that in a way that
secularists can't but good liberals
don't have enough juice in and of them
in and of themselves they don't have
enough juice to fight that that's why
liberalism has collapsed in the name of
progressivism yeah I approach this in
two ways the first one is your comment
that secularism is collapsing and one
can analyze that
Effects of eight years of word leads to
and the millions of people that died in
the last century but coming over to the
other side what you're saying Justin you
see I am a scientist and one of the
fascinating things is that science is a
direct legacy of the judeo-christian
tradition
you were saying we're all scientists now
and all this is no it is not and let's
start absolutely basic in the beginning
God created the heavens and the earth
Hebrew Bible written millennia ago knew
there was a beginning it was in the
early 60s before scientists caught off
of that and the Bible was right and
Dawkins said well there was a 50/50
chance when I debated him and I said at
least the Bible got it right but more
seriously than that you see the fact
that I'm a mathematician and interested
in science I just think about that the
fact that mathematics can describe what
goes on in the universe is a matter of
huge wonder Einstein once said the only
incomprehensible thing about the
universe is that is comprehensible and
he saw the problem why does it work well
it's not an incomprehensible thing if
you start from the idea that there's an
intelligent God who made us in His image
and therefore we can do science and
that's exactly what the early pioneers
of modern science starting with Galileo
and Kepler and Newton and so on and so
forth they were all believers in God and
therefore when I hear that kind of
question I'm not remotely ashamed of
being a scientist and a Christian
because I want to argue that it was
Christianity gave me my subject and CS
Lewis put it brilliantly
[Laughter]
I'm glad you understood it name CS Lewis
said men became scientific because the
expected Lord nature and they expected
Lord nature because they believed in the
lawgiver and I think we're getting to
the stage now for serious atheist
thinkers are beginning to reexamine the
kind of naturalism that produces
everything - physics and chemistry and
one of them lives in New York his name
is Thomas Nagel and he's a brilliant
philosopher and he says something's
going wrong because if everything is
reducible to physics and chemistry then
so is your mind but then why would you
trust your mind
in other words atheism taken to its
logical conclusion undermines the very
rationality you need to trust to do
science and I'm not in for accepting a
worldview that undermines the
foundations of any kind of argument or
discussion whatsoever so I think that in
the 21st century we can push back on
that very naive notion that God's art we
do science now no science actually
brings God back in it's very interesting
I mean
all of this leads me to want to ask you
at this point a you sitting now with
John here tonight obviously a Christian
believer someone who gives evidences for
God and I know that on your show you've
you've had people like Bishop Perrin and
I think Ravi Zacharias is going to be
featured shortly and where does this
leave you on if you like that God
question because one level I can
absolutely see the way in which there's
a kind of a utility and a kind of sense
in which meaning Mamina from doing the
religious things the rituals and so on
but at the end of the day and I asked
mr. Jordan Peterson once it was an
interesting answer do you believe in God
do you feel like that's where you've got
to at this point in your life you know
it's funny when we would do the Q&A is
at the shows with Jordan for the first
few we would let people come up to the
microphone and what usually happens is
that people start telling their life
story and they they would want to get
that therapy session in front of
strangers and it started getting very
weird so we decided we decided a better
way to we used an app to do it and when
Jordan was on stage basically I would go
through the best ones and I'd find some
funny ones and some serious ones and
everything else but what always came up
no matter how many times
Jordan answered it was do you believe in
God and he as I'm sure he said to you he
finds it to be sort of the most annoying
question so I think I would answer it I
mean I would answer it in a similar way
that Jordan would that look I think I've
I've sort of laid out a set of beliefs
here that show the utility of believing
in something outside of myself and I do
I do believe in that so if you want to
call that God that there is something
outside of me there is something that is
connecting all of us that has nothing to
do with the material world there is
something that drives us that that is
the driver of humanity that is something
good I believe that
I don't I can't yeah I believe that but
could you put a name on that something
at this book I told you I wanted to
label it I I guess I I mean in a sense I
I hear what you're saying do I get a
cookie at least come on people what are
you doing here I I guess I guess it's
kind of like what are the particular so
what would that look how is that gonna
make a difference I suppose in your life
is there a sort of sense in which you
feel now any new obligations given this
kind of new sense that there's there is
something beyond you know I think we're
all sort of wired differently right I
think some people can really can really
flourish just sort of on on their own
set of ideas that they create in the
world and I think that can really work
for some people I think some people need
some order outside of that some people
need more of a community some people are
real loners all of those things I think
perhaps but I but I truly mean what I
said before I'd be happy to do this
every year with you and continue
continue these conversations and I'll
continue them on my show obviously I
think for me the adventure of discussing
this and seeing what kind of people that
I bring into my studio that I interact
with that events like this what type of
people I want to be around that really
is the proof that that is what well
that's what makes this right that's what
makes this so I don't know so again I
get what you're gettin I respect the
question truly and it's and it's a it's
B question right I mean it's like saying
what's the meaning of life right it's
that's the big one I would say I'm on
the adventure to finding that out and
and I'm really okay with that you know I
hope that doesn't sound dismissive of
the question or
or or like I'm trying to evade it I'm
really not I like B and maybe this is
just a function also of what I do for a
living I mean I get to sit every week
with people that in most cases are
smarter than me who have spent years
working through all of these issues as
you have John and that is an incredible
privilege that I have so I would like to
see how far I can take them if you're
looking for more honest and thoughtful
conversations about spirituality instead
of non-stop yelling check out our
spirituality playlist and if you want to
watch full interviews on a variety of
topics check out our full episode
playlist there all right over here
and to get notified of all future videos
be sure to subscribe and click the
notification bell